so one way to get some pop for your
podcast one way to get some pop for your
new podcast is to make news
off top and there was a lot of
anticipation of course uh kevin durant
uh aspiring media mogul that he is
uh has a new podcast on his boardroom
podcast network and his first guest
was his uh his teammate not new teammate
you know they've been together for a
year but haven't played uh together but
his teammate with the brooklyn nets
kyrie irving and kyrie irving had some
comments about his excitement about
playing with kevin durant
um that seemed to reflect on a certain
form of teammate of kyries check it out
depends on who's hot
i don't see it as that there's anything
other than that like
three pick and roll or it's a iso for
either one of us or something
great for our our team i'm one thing
i've always been comfortable with is
you know i felt like i was the best
option on every team i played for
you know down the stretch
this is the first time in my career
where i could look down and be like
make that shot too
first time in my career that i could
look down and say that guy can
make that shot
two
your thoughts my
yeah i got lots of thoughts on it okay
where to begin if if
if you were okay with it i'm just gonna
just be real here
on this show if you're okay with it i
would like to take a segment that you
had on a previous show i'd like to take
the name of it the whole concept of it
and do it here it's called doing too
much
and kyrie irving always does that he
always does too much you know he did
that
when he was in boston he felt like he
had to come in i got to be the leader i
got to do this no you don't
he went to brad stevens well you know he
said to
the media he didn't go to brad stevens
he said you know brad's a good coach but
he's never coached anybody like me
and so now he's talking about he's been
the best option
on all the teams that he's played with
he's best option down the stretch
here's a word we we don't use enough
with nba players
it starts with a j jealous
i think kyrie irving is jealous of
lebron james
i really do i think he is i think he is
jealous of
all the attention
that lebron got in cleveland in his in
his home area
i think he he probably is jealous
because he doesn't get
uh enough credit for that game seven
shot
against the warriors
he's jealous he's not been a he's never
been a first-team all-nba player in his
career
i don't know why he would say that but i
think
he's he's he's uh i'm going to put him
in the paul george he's a paul george
he's in the paul george category i've
created a new paul george category in
the nba
that is a category for a player who is
really good
and is an all-star
but not a superstar and by some of the
things that they say and do they'll get
you fired
kyrie irving can get you fired because
he's not as good as he thinks he is but
he's a really good player
and he's jealous uh
interesting um
i would say it's hard to disagree with
when we think about him forcing his way
out of cleveland and no longer wanting
to play with lebron
um when all they were doing was going to
the finals every year
uh and he was still he still had like
the second best-selling shoe so
you know if it if there is something to
what you're saying it always baffled me
that there would be
because
kyrie from a brand standpoint
uh
is flourishing or
was flourishing you know pre-boston
pre-injury
um you know making movies selling
sneakers i mean he's one of the most
high-profile players in the nba
and the difference between him and paul
george i hear you about not as good as
he thinks he is but this dude did get it
done on the biggest stage like let's be
fair to kyrie irving i mean i'm not
taking anything away from lebron james
man it's not just one
it's not just one shot it's that entire
this wasn't right this ain't robert rory
it's not just one no no no no no he's
not that yeah like he doesn't they don't
win that championship in cleveland
without kyrie irving okay and so
i i i would say i hear where you're
going with this category of of guys that
aren't quite where they think they are
but if if if kyrie is in that category
of yours i hope he's at the top of that
list if he is because
of the george category
yeah i mean he's a great player not not
the leader
that and not not the type of person that
would appear to be able to fall apart
you talk bring out the best in everybody
around him i'd love to know more about
why it didn't work in boston and why
boston those young players seem to be
relieved
yes once he was gone or is that yeah but
it's exactly what i said he comes in and
he just kind of just
goes to he goes too far he's that guy
you know you're at the cookout you're
having a good time and he brings up a
topic he's like oh man like
people start leaving you know you know
what man look at the time i
i gotta get going man
man why are you bringing that up why are
you bringing that up
and so
uh one of my favorite quotes allegedly i
got to say allegedly even though i
believe it i want to believe it okay
one of my favorite quotes is uh he went
into brad stevens and said to him
what does government mean to you
that's
what
what do you mean i guess he's just
trying to test to see
you know if his coach is down or not and
he is you know brad stevens is that guy
he's that guy that you know he's the
ally that you're looking for
but i think
he is a he's a he's a great talent mike
uh who probably is not going to be your
number one
lead do it all
lead you and play at that level he's not
that kind of guy okay i i do want to
point out something though because kyrie
i mean we give kyrie a lot of grief and
he certainly got a lot for the whole
flat earth thing um you know a while
back excuse me but
when they decided to go to the bubble
kyrie
reportedly
was outspoken about hey we got work to
do in the real world
you know we don't we don't need to be in
a bubble
when we need to be
as much as we can be as nba players on
the front lines advocating for racial
and social justice this is going to be a
distraction
right and then and people and people
were like oh that's just kyra that's
just flat earth guy this is kyrie being
shut up kyrie shut up kyrie you can do
both at the same time
fast forward to jacob blake and kenosha
and what are they meeting about
what are they voting about
whether or not
we should stay in this bubble when the
world is on fire
outside of it
so i'm just i'm just trying i'm trying
to be fair
to kyrie
i i don't i mean i'm not i'm not saying
it that doesn't take away from
everything you're saying that's gonna
take me from everything you're saying no
no no two things we drew at the same
time he could be hard to coach and and
hard as a teacher
i'm just bringing up an example though
i'm glad you brought i'm speaking out
because sometimes that crazy relative at
the cookout actually says some stuff
that people might not want to hear but
there's something to it
yeah listen i think that's i think that
is valuable what he said and i think
it's accurate
and and we
you know at that time
i think
uh a lot of a lot of people were guilty
of listening
to the messenger without the message
they were shooting the messenger exactly
yes because because it's kyrie and you
know kyrie
is provocative sometimes he you know he
says some things he does some things
he's just a little different a different
kind of cat
but i think he he brought up a brilliant
point i agree with him on that yeah i
mean i think it was worthy of discussion
those who didn't go to the bubble i
didn't criticize anybody who didn't go
to the bubble this is not an
across-the-board issue everybody had a
different situation so yeah i'm with him
on that
i'm not i think he's full of it though
on this comment
yeah okay i love it yeah let me let me
get to that real quick
so because it's interesting if you do
think he's jealous of lebron
i mean he's not the best player
on his own team now
you know and so he seems to be enthused
about playing with kevin durant my issue
with kyrie in this context as it relates
to this comment about i'm finally with a
guy it's twofold actually i got i got
two issues and then we gotta get to the
other thing he said before we get to
chris sims we got okay we gotta get
another thing that came out of this out
of this podcast before i give you my
two-fold issue with what's going on why
i have an issue with this uh this
comment
about uh that we assume is you know
reflective of lebron james first time
he's been with somebody that he feels
like can make these this big-time shot
um the lack of self-awareness
and maybe you don't care what people
think
or maybe you don't care how people take
it maybe you're just being honest
but you gotta know
that dude you play with one of the
greatest players of all time and and
you're gonna say publicly this is the
first time i've ever been able to look
across and say that guy could
that guy can make that shot well that
says a lot about your evaluation skills
it says a lot about your relationship or
lack thereof with lebron james says a
lot about your chemistry and honestly
i'm like you are ungrateful you know
what because i mean like just just like
i said that lebron doesn't have that
championship without kyrie kyrie doesn't
have a championship you don't have a
game seven
to win with a big shot without the king
so you're telling me it's the first time
i look over like dude who do you think
you are
which brings me to my second point
yep the definition of clutch this
antiquated outdated definition of clutch
clutch is not one shot
you know with with time running down i
thought we graduated and evolved as a
species and as a sporting public to
understand that clutch is not three two
one hero ball right i thought we were
past that
i thought we were past that
because clutch is you brought up lebron
in game six in boston that's clutch
winning that game is clutch
just clutch is the last we we've we have
we have an analytical definition of
clutch now which is the last five
minutes of the game with the score
within five points
so look if you want to talk numbers look
at lebron's clutch stats in those
situations throughout his career for the
people that didn't think he was clutch
and if you want to talk about big shots
he's clearly made big shots he's made
big plays he's made the right passes
in those situations so the idea of like
reducing this whole thing to somebody
who can take and make that shot ask
yourself whether you should be taking
that shot because a lot of times that
ain't the best play iso ball the best
play
man
i i tell you
now i have
i i have i have shown
that i can
i can i can look at a statement i've
made in the past and if the information
changes
so what does it mean facts change so in
my opinion yeah absolutely
i'm gonna tell you this
bad combination of kevin durant
and kyrie irving irving in brooklyn why
they're both talented obviously
but if i if i wanted to uh if i wanted
to distract them
if i'm an opponent of theirs you know
what i do this is what i do i'm telling
this this is this is evil
but i'm going to tell you anyway this is
evil
i'm intrigued if
if i'm if i'm if i'm milwaukee
if i'm boston if i'm miami what i would
do this is straight out of the godfather
you know some people in the movie you
know some people in the media right oh
you got some people in the media on the
payroll
i would have somebody on the payroll in
print
and on air and i would say just talk
about them
just talk about these guys because i
think that is their weakness i don't
think they deal with criticism well
and i think that's when that they're
going to implode from that you watch
it's it's not their talent they kevin
durant still
as a storyteller he should know this is
how it works but he's so thin skinned
and like if you say anything about him
then he just loses his mind and i know i
read the same way i got a burner got
burner account yeah absolutely same way
that's what i do
it's not going to work so wait
wait hold on okay did you did you see
what else kyrie said on this podcast
maybe i don't know if you missed it okay
he talked about steve nash now remember
we all knew this oh yeah
they don't hire steve nash
without the blessing of their superstars
i don't really see us having a
quote-unquote head coach
katie could be a head coach i could be a
favorite guy some days
could be a head coach could do it one
day it's a collaborative effort
steve
steve
bounce baby bounce bounce do it like
it's okay
leave leave i tell you steve steve nash
you know like some some pretty you know
those presidential photos when you how
you look when you come in and the way
you look on the way out
that's what happened to you
that's what happened to you in six
months if you stay on this job see the
funny thing is the funny thing is in the
nfl there's no illusion and we can talk
to uh chris sims about this there's no
illusion in the nfl the head coach is is
in charge and part of it is you don't
really have a guaranteed contract so you
can't be really be running things in the
nfl
because okay it's not the dynamic that
way in the nba the beauty is
the best coaches will make you think
that you're it's a partnership
yes but they're you're pretty much doing
what they want but they make you feel
empowered but this dude is not even on
that this dude was saying well this
nash you're a partner with me
i mean that's i i i
steve i just
yeah that i hope
this the one time you're gonna hear me
quote
south carolina senator tim scott
uh i think he misspoke
and if he misspoke i hope he corrects it
i hope he corrects it
um because oh that is such
bs like if we don't have ash we having a
meeting tomorrow
night
and we thought they were going to be
talking about who taking the last shot
this is like oh
we got we got we'll i'll be the head
coach one day the hell you will he ain't
joking oh my god
he didn't i know he's serious
he's not john i'm telling you that's too
much cookout's over he just ended the
cookout again
good luck
[Music]
you